what's the deal with everything peanuts
peanuts what's the difference with
specifically with podcasting and let's
even just say success with New York
comedians now in L.A meetings well I
think New York comedians tend to try to
be funny I do have a serious hatred for
the LA comedy scene now are you in over
at the store can you no you can't get
spots okay they're Chumps outside of the
newly built comedy Mothership The Comedy
Store in LA and The Comedy seller in New
York are debatably two of the most
famous comedy clubs in human history in
fact it would be nearly impossible to
name a single Modern Day comedian who
wasn't a regular at the store or the
seller at some point in their careers
but the way these two clubs treat
comedians specifically ones from the
opposing City could not be more
different on paper most people would
assume the New York club might act more
cold and clicky towards Outsiders while
the California venue would be more
open-minded and accepting but in reality
it seems to be the exact opposite the
seller gives us everything the seller
treats us like kings they should yeah
everything we want they give us they
make us feel like at home we love it
there I love it and I'm mad that our
club doesn't have the same it should be
reciprocation reciprocation right it
should feel the same you know East Coast
and West coast rappers no more war yeah
peace yeah yeah reciprocate yeah
reciprocate y'all not give a about
death row yeah you know what's so funny
yeah it is they do treat I mean the
people over there at seller I I've
talked about on the show they treat it's
so nice it's not just and it should feel
that way when guys come here I prefer it
in a weird way the comedy store has gone
through many different ups and downs
during its remarkable history from the
original Glory Days with Richard Pryor
to the first Dark Ages followed by the
return of Rogan in 2015 and the insane
comedy boom that came with it when the
nightly lineups at the store would be 10
of the best comics in the world
performing one after another however
most people in 2023 would argue The
Comedy Store is experiencing another
Dark Age obviously Joe Rogan and Mitzi
Shore aren't around anymore in almost
all of the star power and comedy right
now see seems to be located around
Austin Texas and New York City I do have
a serious hatred for the LA comedies oh
I want to hear all about it they're
Chumps they're all phonies it's the
worst every single one of them God damn
they're all so addicted to their Fame
that they're so afraid of it going away
that not not a single one of them has
they used to a couple of them had some
morals and then Diaz left Segura left
and it's just like what is even left
there yeah who's at all standing up for
the right side of yeah they're
garbage who is it now and who's who's
running the comedy store now it's like
you know Rogan was like the guy I guess
that's like what a vacuum's created
after like Paul Castellano gets whacked
or Saddam Hussein leaves or Saddam
Hussein leaves you like his does the U.S
military need to go into the comedy
store and try to set up you know I think
it's more egalitarian now it's pretty
cool I'm sorry oh that always works it's
like an equal yeah
[Laughter]
um
yeah like people like uh fahima Santino
or just like everyone's just having a
good time doing stand up this is why
it's so bizarre to think established
joke machines like Mark Norman and Sam
Morrell would be having any sort of
trouble getting spots at the store right
now these New York guys are capable of
instantly adding value to any comedy
lineup in the world and it's insane to
think that there's venues who wouldn't
want them as a surprise or announced
guest maybe three years ago it could
have been hard to squeeze in an outsider
on nights like this when you had Tom
Segura Chris D'Elia Anthony Jeselnik Joe
Rogan Theo Von Joey Diaz Andrew Santino
Donnell Rawlings and Tony Hinchcliffe
all going up one after another but today
only three of those names remain in Los
Angeles and out of those three one of
them is currently banned from The Comedy
Store and another one is flirting with
moving to the Big Apple himself wanted
to change though I do want to come here
for a while because I want to feel
something different for a while what do
you want to feel
I just want a new scene man I want a new
I want to I want to do I want to work
the clubs here and I also want a just a
little bit different trying to find
yourself you know yeah this is this is
your India you know what
this is this is you know what I've said
before I'm 40 this year yeah oh I
don't like midlife crisis I like midlife
assessment you're reassessing where
you're going and what you want I hate
the terms
it's a midlife
one of the weirder Parts about this
entire situation is that all the
comedians themselves seem to be in
agreement yet not much progress has been
made so far besides when Bobby Lee made
this promise to Mark and Sam on we might
be drunk what I'm saying to use this
okay is is that you can't just show up
and go I want to go up right now we're
not doing that if you could come in if
you we know you're coming through right
on a Sunday like everyone else and you
call and go I'm available these nights
they will give you spots okay that's all
I'm saying all right well who do I mean
I go through my agent just because
you're getting rejected just text me
okay I will text Emily and I will do it
for you it seems pretty complicated it's
not complicated we're making it
complicated okay because the thing is um
your your butts hurt and I get it wow no
I get it Sam because you deserve it you
deserve any spot that you get but you
know there's a there was a system in La
that was set a long time ago sure right
and you know things you know
institutions it takes a while for them
to change sure okay Catholic Church
Jesus Christ
speaking of established New York
comedians there's a brand new podcast
featuring Bobby Kelly Dan Soder Joe list
and Louis J Gomez called the regs that
premiered earlier this month Bobby you
just chose you just picked and chose
yeah
I wasn't late I was on time you guys I
just want to let you know they don't do
this on protect our Parks they don't
fight like this what is that
the concept behind starting the show was
to take four of the biggest you know
what dude fan favorite regulars and put
them together to create a new spin-off
podcast the first episode performed
really well on YouTube with over 185 000
views in just 12 days if you're a fan of
gas digital or you know what dude you're
really gonna love this podcast because
the Vibes are extremely similar which is
basically four funny dudes arguing with
each other about stuff that literally
doesn't matter at all for almost two
hours guest spots from last week The Joe
Rogan Experience had on Tim Dillon and
post Malone two bears 1K Dave was Burton
Tom and Burke kill Tony this week was
with Brian Moses and Matthew Broussard
ymh talked about the Yoshi the Tim
Dillon show featured Eli Roth flagrant
had on that Mexican OT Mike Cannon was
on hey babe we might be drunk with a
huge episode with Jeffrey asmus Brian
Simpson Daniel Sloss and Ali McCoskey
Jared freed was on stavy's world and
Jordan Jensen and Rick Glassman were the
guests on the Adam Friedland show Adam
tell me that you're sad because you lost
a lot of money in a little further away
shot
I'm sad because I lost a lot of money oh
that sucks man I'm sorry I'm sorry I
don't think that's good acting you're
wrong stop for one second go closer I'll
show you good but let me do let me make
my point before you show me anything
now let me show you tight now say it
again Rick I'm I'm pretty sad because I
just lost a lot of money
I'm sorry
okay that's not good acting and I'll
show you good acting okay I want to try
next reverse so to him yeah I know I'm
just nothing directing to Adam Adam to
him sorry I'm just in a bad mood
why I just lost so much money
so you okay as an actor you have to know
where the camera is and I'm three steps
ahead of you bud this past weekend with
the Yvonne had on Ric Flair whiskey
Ginger spoke with Dana Carvey the blocks
podcast talked with Adam DeVine taste
buds battle Batman vs Wolverine Sam
Talent was on the Honeydew Jim Norton
was on first date taiso had on Lisa
Gilroy are you garbage with just the
fellas Corey Feldman was a guest on the
Harland Highway you know what dude
talked with Matthew Broussard and tiger
belly had on Andy Richter as far as new
stand-up specials are either out right
now or coming out soon Matt mccusker's
speed of light is out right now on
YouTube and is quickly approaching a
million views as we speak Nick Griffin
also has a new special out right now on
the 800 pound gorilla channel that
comedy fans have really seemed to be
enjoying so far your is so good
thanks buddy and if you're not watching
watch the Letterman says yes a new
special absolutely wonderful it's just
like they're just it's great for
literally every generation because it's
relatable it's yeah it's relatable and
it's just such concise smart writing and
it's got emotion in it you somehow pack
a lot of emotion in these quick Punchy
jokes is hard to do we also have a few
new specials that are in the works right
now but coming out soon Trevor Wallace
just completed filming for his special
in Austin although no word on her
release date yet we do have a release
date for Joe list however who will be
uploading his new hour to YouTube on
August 18th at 10 pm Eastern with all of
this new comedy coming out soon from so
many different talented comedians it's
harder than ever to stay up to date with
all your favorite guys which is why it's
so important to subscribe to joke world
if you want to stay in the comedy Loop
and for all you longtime subscribers who
are interested in some free joke World
stickers we just got about 200 of these
new what's deal with airplane peanut
designs that we're sending out
completely free to whoever fills out the
form in our Instagram bio please be sure
to include your full mailing address so
we can ensure that these arrive safely
and on time you're also going to get
some regular joke World logo ones like
the sign behind me as well as this new
design what's the deal with airplane
peanuts thank you for watching
at joke world
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out